现在是零成两点钟,其实我正在度假,但是我现在起的受招,我觉得事情我一定要说出来
就是我之前不分享一些,我个人觉得很朋友的产品
但有时候会收到一些不同的一千反饭,那以前我都觉得这些很正常的事情
毕竟呼呼比你这个东西,他确实是一软一导
但是前面今天我看了一个品牌,唱成的访坛,他就爆出了一个行业黑路
就是有的品牌,刚出意一款产品,他的用料会非常跑,你会感觉很好用
因为他们需要这样的第一批货来打市场
但是后面的货可能就和前面的不一样了,后面就开始偷工检料了
这就让我想到了之前我收到一款非常好的产品
我用完之后,就去他们店里连回购了
但我回购之后发现他不好用了
我以为是我自己用有了产生耐受了,但是我这次出来对习国外他们家的使用装带出来了
我发现他的使用装非常好用
所以我是真的确定的这件事情,很多时候博主收到的样品是真的很好用
所以他才会分享给大家,是粉丝们买回去了这个产品
你可能会博主动的不一样,我真的是,我真的上面气死了
这种品牌你们这种行为真的很可恥
被希望这种品牌你们不要再来找我合作,不要浪费大家时间了
以后我的学品就会更加的言格
坚决不会让这种品牌出现在莫得直播间和主义的里面
人员之间的信任就是被这种事情被搞美的
在以后品牌给我记了样时候我还会去其他的去到购买
一阴的对比,近我最大的努力,让粉丝买到的和我用到的产品
这种品牌也请您好自累资